>> Good morning everyone.
>> Good morning.
>> Welcome to the
Library of Congress.
Who's been here before?
>> Me.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Hi,
welcome back.
And, who is here for
the very first time?
Welcome. I'm so glad
you guys are here.
We have such a special
program for you today.
We have two special guests
and we're going to start
with somebody who works with me.
So, my name is Sasha
Dowdy and I work here
in the Young Readers Center.
We're the space for
kids under 16.
Everybody under 16 here?
So, this is a space just
for you in this library,
the biggest library in the
world, so you own this space.
This is a pretty
good place to be.
And, the person who works
with me, my colleague,
his name is Ahmed Johnson.
He works in Library Services
in a division called
History and Genealogy.
Everybody know what history is?
>> Yes.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Everybody
know what genealogy is?
>> No.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Right,
that's exactly how I
wanted to hear that.
So, Ahmed is going to tell you
all about what genealogy means,
what he does with it and
what it has anything to do
with our program today.
So, how about we
welcome Ahmed Johnson.
[ Applause ]
>> Ahmed Johnson: Thank
you so much Sasha.
Once again, my name is Ahmed,
Ahmed Johnson and I work here
at the Library of Congress.
And, my specialty is
African American Genealogy.
And, what does that mean?
Can anybody tell me
what genealogy means?
No. Nobody.
Genealogy is the study
of your family history.
Okay. So, is anyone interested
in maybe what their grandparents
were doing at your age,
maybe their great-grandparents
and so on?
Well, here at the Library
of Congress, we have books
where people have documented
their family histories, okay.
And, you can come here, and you
can search our catalogs and see
if we have anything
relevant to your family.
Can everybody see
this chart here?
What's this?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Ahmed Johnson:
It's a family tree.
And, the most interesting thing
about this family tree is,
it's not my family but
it's the Blackwell family
and it goes back to 1789.
>> Wow.
>> Ahmed Johnson: How
many years ago was that?
Can anybody tell me?
About 300 years, yes exactly.
Good answer.
So, here's an example
of what happens is,
people donate their
family histories
to the Library of
Congress, okay.
And, I also have a picture.
So, what I want everyone to do
over the Thanksgiving
break is ask questions.
Ask your parents about their
parents and their parents
and so forth and then I
want you to document it.
I have handouts over here
where you could document
this information, okay?
Because one day, what do I want?
I want your family history to be
here at the Library of Congress.
Everybody good with that?
>> Yeah.
>> Ahmed Johnson: Can I
get a hand clap for that?
All right, so I have
another goodie here.
This is a picture of my family.
This is my grandmother
at the age of 2,
she's now 98 years old.
So, I'm showing you this
to encourage you to
do the same thing.
Look for pictures.
Look in a photo album,
find pictures,
document the information that
you find from the picture.
Now, I'm going to
pass this around,
but this is very valuable to me.
So, what do I want?
I want it back, because this
is a treasure in my family,
so I'm going to start
right here and take a look
at that picture, okay.
And, at the end of the program,
if you have any questions,
I'm here to answer them.
Thank you so much guys.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Sasha Dowdy: Thank you very
much and you guys can learn
so much more about genealogy.
You can work with your
teachers and your family
to look what you can find
at the Library of Congress.
You can come in person
or you can go online,
so that's pretty cool.
So, next up we have our author
guest today, Megan McDonald,
she is an author
of so many books.
She's written some
picture books.
chapter books.
Who here has heard of "Stink"?
Who's heard of "Judy Moody"?
This is the author of
Judy Moody and Stink,
she also writes all
kinds of stories.
She gathers stories
and she shares them
and there was even a movie made
about one of her books, yeah,
the Judy, yeah exactly
you guys are fans here,
so how about we hear
from Megan McDonald
about the newest book she
wrote in the Judy Moody series
and what it has to
do with genealogy.
So how about we welcome
here, Megan McDonald.
[ Applause ]
>> Megan McDonald: Thank you.
Thank you everybody.
I'm so happy to be here and
I want to thank the Library
of Congress and First
Book and Candlewick Press
for all working together
to bring me here
to talk with you today.
Most of my Judy Moody and Stink
stories come from my family,
from a story that really
happened in my family.
So, you're going to hear a
lot about my big sisters.
I have four older sisters;
don't you feel sorry for me?
Four. But actually,
growing up with sisters,
a lot of funny things happened
and I'd like to make them happen
to my characters
in the books, okay.
I'm going to tell you a lot
about my new book, "Judy Moody
and the Right Royal Tea Party",
but first I wanted to start
out showing you, I
thought it would be fun,
you get to see the book when
it's all finished and it's
in the library, hopefully all of
the mistakes are fixed by then
and all the pictures are done,
but I thought it would be fun
to show you, since I'm a writer,
well what does it really look
like when I first start to
write a Judy Moody book?
Okay, so here's what
it actually looks like.
Here's how a book
starts for me, ta-da.
Do you know what this is?
>> A napkin!
>> Megan McDonald:
It's a napkin.
Most people use it to wipe
their mouth after lunch right?
But I'm a writer, so
I write on anything.
If I get a great idea for Judy
Moody, I might not be at home,
I might not have my computer
or I might not have my notebook
with me, so I just scribble
it on whatever I have,
something like a napkin.
On this napkin if you could see
in the middle here, it says,
instead of Judy Moody, it
says, Judy Muddy and that idea,
the funny sound of
mixing up her name,
that idea became the whole
book, "Judy Moody Gets Famous".
In that book, Judy decides she's
going to try some funny ways
to get, to try to become
famous and get her picture
in the newspaper, but the
thing that she thinks up is,
she decides her, she finds out
there's a famous pet contest
at the pet store and in
the pet contest, if you,
if your pet has a
really good pet trick,
you can enter your pet in
the contest, if your pet wins
for the best trick then
you get your picture taken
with your pet in the newspaper.
So, Judy has a cat named
Mouse and Judy is sure
that Mouse is going to
be her ticket to fame,
to getting her picture in
the paper, because Mouse,
I'll put him on, her
up on the screen.
Oh, here's the napkin a little
bit bigger so you can see
where it says Judy Muddy there
and here's the book
I'm referring
to in Judy Moody Gets Famous.
So, Mouse has a special talent,
she knows how to make toast.
Her cat can push down the
little button on the toaster
and up pops the toast.
And, Judy's like, what can be
a better pet trick than a cat
who makes toast, right.
So, she's sure they're going to
win the contest and she's going
to get her picture in the
paper, but when she gets
to the pet store, there's a
chicken who plays the piano.
So, Judy gets, Judy
and Mouse get beat
out by the piano playing
chicken, so instead of winning,
she gets second place,
but she thinks, hey,
at least I'll still get my
picture in the paper, right.
So, when the photographer
goes to snap the picture,
just as she scoops up Mouse
and has her cat in her arms,
and just as the photographer
goes to take the picture,
Mouse leaps out of her arm and
scratches her and Judy goes,
aah!, like this, and instead
of her face, the only thing
that gets in the picture
in the paper is her elbow.
So, instead of getting famous,
she just has one
famous elbow, poor Judy.
But now she thinks, okay, even
though it's just my elbow,
it'll say my name under
the caption in the picture,
right and everybody'll
that's me Judy Moody.
And, she goes to read her
name in the paper and instead
of Judy Moody, the
newspaper made a mistake
and they spelled her name wrong.
They called her Judy Muddy.
So, that was the idea
when I first thought
of that something could
go wrong when she tries
to get her picture in the paper.
I scribbled it down
on the napkin
and that's how it all started.
Then after I was thinking
about what could go wrong,
I remembered something really
funny that happened to me
when I first became a published
writer, I got my picture
in the paper and I thought
it would be so exciting
to see my picture in the paper.
So, the day it came out,
I went to the store
and I made a mistake.
I should've just looked inside
the newspaper first to make sure
that I would want anybody
to see the picture of me,
but I didn't look inside.
I bought a bunch of papers
and I brought them home
and when I got home and
I opened the newspaper,
I couldn't believe my eyes.
The newspaper made a mistake
and instead of the picture of me
for the author Megan
McDonald, they printed a pic,
a different picture with
my name in the paper,
so I brought it to
show you today.
Here's the picture
of the children's book
writer, Megan McDonald.
Okay, ready?
[ Laughter ]
>> Megan McDonald: What?!
It's a guy!
So, this is the picture
that was me.
If you're not sure
who this guy is,
because you might think
it's Elvis or something,
but if you're not
sure who he is,
it says Megan McDonald
pictured, so everybody
who read the newspaper that
day thought this guy was Megan
McDonald, the children's
book author.
So, things can, things that
go, even things that go wrong
that happen to you
or funny things
like that can become
a story in a book.
But my favorite way to get ideas
is, I like to take funny things
that really happen like family
stories from when I was your age
and put them in my
book, so I'm going
to tell you a family story.
I'll tell you the true story
of what really happened,
then I'll show you how
I change it for by book.
Okay, but in real life, this is
a story of a really funny joke
that I got to play
on my sisters.
And, when you're the youngest
of five, your older sis,
my older sisters were
always pranking me
and playing jokes on me.
But one time, this is
the one time I remember
when I got my sisters so
good, so I wanted to put
that family story
in my book, okay.
But in real life,
my whole family,
we grew up in Pennsylvania,
but we got to come
to Washington D.C., and we were
just here to visit our friends,
but when we got here my
mom and dad were like,
hey it's the Capitol and it's
where the White House is,
we could go take a tour.
So, my mom and my dad
and all four sisters,
all got to take a tour.
They went to the White House.
Back then it was
a long time ago,
so a man named John F.
Kennedy was the president.
And, my mom, dad, and all four
sisters got to go take a tour
of the White House
when he was president.
I was too little.
They said, I would get
bored and I would cry,
so I had to stay home
with our friends.
But I was so disappointed
because when you're
the youngest,
you want to do everything your
big sisters get to do, right.
So, I wanted to go, even though
I didn't know what the White
House was, I was too little,
but I knew I wanted to go.
Well, I was so disappointed,
I stayed home with the friends
and the friends were
trying to cheer me up.
And, to cheer me up,
they got out this box,
they had with all
these cool toys
from when their kids
were little.
They said I could play with
whatever I wanted in the box
and if I found one
thing I really like,
they said I could use
it, I could keep it
and take it home with me.
So, I went all through the
box, and as soon as I saw it,
I knew exactly which
thing I was going to keep,
because I knew I could use it
to play a really funny joke
on my sisters while they were
at the White House and I wasn't.
And, the thing was, if anybody,
has anybody here read the
first Judy Moody book?
If you've read the first book,
you might've guessed,
but the thing was.
>> A hand.
>> Megan McDonald: Yes,
a fake hand and it looked
so real even though
it's just plastic.
It looked really real.
So, I took the fake hand and
I'm like, this is really going
to freak out my sisters, right.
I went all over our friend's
house and I was like,
what would be the absolute
best place to put the fake hand
to really freak out my sisters?
So, after I went through all the
rooms, I got to the bathroom.
You knew it?
You guessed.
See, I think like a kid, right?
And, I was like, hey, I
know, how about the toilet?
So, I made sure nobody
was watching and I went
into the bathroom and I
lifted up the toilet seat
and I made the fake hand
stick out of the toilet.
It looks like it's
reaching out to get you.
And, then, so I setup the joke,
then I waited for my sisters
to come home from
the White House.
It took them forever.
They were there all day
and when they got back,
they were so excited
about everything they had
seen at the White House.
They were talking, talking,
talking, I was hardly listening,
because all I could think about
is when is somebody going to go
in that bathroom and find what?
The hand. And, finally my sister
Michelle went into the bathroom
and she goes in there
and shuts the door
and like two seconds later,
we hear this like ahh,
this really big scream
and she came running
out of the bathroom, no lie.
She goes mom, dad, there's
somebody in the toilet.
And, we were cracking up so bad,
my sisters are all grown
ups now, it doesn't matter,
when we all get together, we
still like to tell the story
of the fake hand in the toilet.
So, I decided, hey, that's
a funny story from my family
that I'm going to have happen
to my characters, but of course,
when you're writing you
can use your imagination,
it doesn't have to be
exactly like real life.
So, you can make up whatever
you want to happen right?
So, I decided in my book that
Stink would be the one who gets
to go to the White House,
he's the youngest like me.
So, he would get to go and Judy,
his older sister would
have to stay home.
So, Stink decides he's
going on this field trip
to the White House,
he decides he's going
to dress up like a human flag.
So, he gets an old red and
white striped tablecloth
and he dresses up
like a human flag.
He puts all the stars for
the 48 states on his hat.
What did he do wrong?
You guys are in 5th
grade, so you know.
There's 50 states, right?
So, he forgot there, he forgot
about two really important
states, Hawaii and Alaska,
so Judy helps him
with the right number,
put the right number
of stars on his hat.
He goes off on his field trip
to the White House, but Judy has
to go to school that day.
It's a regular school day
and when she gets to school
that day, it just happens to be
brush your teeth week at school.
During brush your teeth week,
two dentists come to school,
Mr. Tooth and Mrs. Floss.
They dress up like a tooth
and a box of dental floss.
And, they're there to tell you
all about brushing your teeth,
but Judy is like, I already
know how to brush my teeth
and Stink gets to go
on this great adventure
to the White House.
Well, to make matters even
worse, out of all the kids
in the kids in the school
they pick Judy Moody.
She has to come up
in front of everybody
and she has to be the cavity.
So, Stink gets to
be a human flag,
Judy has to be an old
tooth with a hole in it.
And, now she's in
a bad, mad mood,
and that's when she gets
the idea, hey, I know,
I'm going to play a funny
joke on Stink while he's
at the White House and I'm
not, sound familiar right.
So, Judy played, plays
the same joke I did,
she borrows the fake hand
from her friend Rocky,
and she goes all over the house
and she puts the fake hand
in the toilet just like I did.
So, when Stink gets home from
the White House, he finally goes
into the bathroom and when he
sees the fake hand it freaks him
out and he comes screaming
out of the bathroom and all
of the stars for the 50 states
go flying off of his hat.
So, that's just one example
of how I take a family story
from my own family and
make it happen in my book.
If you guys like to write and
illustrate your own books,
you can do the same
thing and of course,
with genealogy you can even go
back further and tell a story
about a grandma or
grandpa or somebody
that goes back even
further in your family.
Kids, often when I'm speaking,
kids will ask me, what other,
did you write any other
books besides Judy Moody?
So, I brought a few to show you,
I'm going to skip ahead here.
My very first book that I ever
got published is this book
called, "Is This a
House for Hermit Crab?"
and it was a book I told
before I became a writer,
I was a librarian, a children's
librarian and I told stories
at the library all the time and
this was based on a story I told
at the library, just a story
about a hermit crab walking
on the beach, looking
for just the right home.
So, before there was Judy Moody,
I wrote a lot of picture books,
one about a grumpy
princess called,
"The Hinky Pink" a really
exciting true-life story called,
"Saving the Liberty Bell".
This is historical fiction,
and this is a true story
of a time during the
American Revolution.
We don't usually get this, hear
this story in our history books,
I'm not sure why
because it's so exciting.
During the revolution,
the British were coming
into Philadelphia, they wanted
to capture the Liberty Bell
and melt down all the
metal from the bell
and would've even had the
Liberty Bell if they did that.
So, a group of farmers from
Allentown, Pennsylvania,
decided, hey, we, the Liberty
Bell is our somebody of freedom,
we don't want it melted down,
so they got all their
farmers wagons
and at midnight one night,
under the cover of darkness,
they snuck into Philadelphia
and they cap,
they took down the Liberty
Bell and they hid it
on the farmer's wagon.
They covered it with straw
and a lady's old hoop skirt,
and they took it all the way
back through the night to,
back to Allentown where they
were from and they hid it
in the basement of
a church there.
And, you can still, I got to go
when I was researching
this book.
You can still go to this
basement of the church and see
where the bell was hidden
and they have a replica
of the bell there.
And, I found out all the
farmers were grownups,
but one farmer took his
11-year-old boy with him,
so I told the story
from the 11-year-old boy
that went on that trip.
A friend of mine who
is an illustrator,
drew this wonderful picture of
a dog who likes to eat, what?
>> Shoes.
>> Megan McDonald: So, that
became a book I did called,
"Shoe Dog" and if you like
Judy Moody books or if you
like funny stories, some of
the funny stories of growing
up with all my sisters, I use
a lot of those funny stories
in my books about
The Sister's Club.
This is about three sisters
instead of five and each one is,
there story is told
in a different voice
from each sister's
point of view.
And, there are some great sister
stories, when you have a lot
of sisters, there's always
a lot of hair disasters
and when my sisters were
teenagers, the style was
to have, we all have curly
hair, but the style was
to have straight hair.
So, my sisters to
get straight hair,
use to iron their hair
on the ironing board.
Yeah, they would take,
they had long hair
and they literally
like, would lean over,
lay it out on the ironing board,
you get the iron really hot
and then you iron the
hair to make it straight.
Well, remember what I
said about hair disasters?
One time my sister was
getting her hair ironed
and another sister was
ironing it and the phone rang
and in those days, we
didn't have cell phones.
You had to go in the other room
and answer the phone
on the wall, right.
So, she went to answer the
phone, but she put the iron.
>> She left the iron
on her hair.
>> Megan McDonald: You guys are
storytellers, you already know.
She left the iron on her
hair and when she came back
from the phone, all this smoke
was coming up from her hair
and when she lifted up the iron,
there was like a big, you know,
how an iron is like a triangle?
There was a big shape of
the iron that got burned
out of the back of her hair,
so I retell that story in one
of my Sister's Club books.
Here's a picture of the four
sisters I've been telling you
about when they were
young and my mom.
This is, I wanted to show
you a picture of the sisters
from when they were young,
from when we were growing up.
So, I told my sisters that I put
this photo in the show for you
and they're like, well you have
to show everybody a picture
of you, because you're
not in this picture.
So, I made a mistake, I told
my sisters they could choose
which picture I would show you
today, so here's the picture
of me that they chose
to show you.
They said, we're
picking this picture
because it's the best way to
show how I went from a kid
to grow up into somebody
who writes
about a girl with
a lot of moods.
Okay, so here's me.
[ Laughter ]
>> Megan McDonald: This
is me when I was probably
like 2 years old or something
and my mom and dad just wanted
to take a nice, they
dressed me up and they wanted
to take a nice picture of
me, and I was not having it.
I would not get my
picture taken.
I, Megan McDonald was in a mood.
So, I went over to the neighbors
and I laid down with my face
on the driveway and I was
kicking my feet, and my sister,
the one I played the joke on,
she had just gotten a little
brownie camera for her birthday,
she came out and
took a whole roll
of pictures throwing a tantrum
on the neighbors driveway,
so that's, we can
that one Megan Moody.
Here's me today.
Kids, readers often
ask me where I write,
so there's a little room
upstairs in my house
where I have a lot of, like Judy
Moody, I like to collect stuff,
so you can see some of the th--
Judy Moody has some
funny collections like,
she collects pizza tables,
you know, those little things
in the pizza box that hold
the lid up from getting
in the cheese and this
is the giant jawbreaker.
I think I might own the world's
biggest jawbreaker maybe.
But that jawbreaker
inspired "Stink
and the Incredible
Super-Galactic Jawbreaker".
Judy collects Band-Aids, she
admires Elizabeth Blackwell
who was the first woman to
become a doctor in our country.
If you could believe
it, there was a time
where only boys could
go to medical school.
And, Elizabeth Blackwell thought
that wasn't fair, so she applied
and became the first doctor,
so Judy collects Band-Aids,
because she admires
Elizabeth Blackwell and wants
to be a doctor when
she grows up.
And, then if you look right
here, she, Judy also collects A,
B, oh yeah, you see the
hand, where's the hand?
Oh yeah, it's right up here.
I have a little mini version.
She collects ABC gum.
Do you guys know what that is?
ABC stands for already
been chewed.
So, when we made the
movie of Judy Moody,
one of the things I got to
do to help with the movie is,
I got to help the artist
tell them what might be
in Judy Moody's room and
pick out some of the stuff
that got to be in her room.
And, I said, well she has to
have her ABC gum collection,
so the artist on the movie made
a whole collection out of clay
to look like it's gum
that's already been chewed
and they put it on that
little board and they,
they even made a name
for every flavor of gum
and they hung it on the door.
So, when you watch the movie,
if you look in her room,
you will be able to see
the ABC gum collection.
I also wanted to show
you a rough draft.
This is what it really looks
like when I'm working
on Judy moody.
This is from the very first book
and my editor is here today,
so I can't say anything bad.
But she's the one
with the red pen,
I'm the one with the typewriting
and she has a lot of opinions
and suggestions, oddly enough.
Of course, when I first send her
the book, I think it's perfect
and it doesn't need to
change at all, right,
but she never things so,
she always finds suggestions
and things, and it's
actually great
because it makes it
a much better book.
She cuts out all the boring
parts, so you guys don't have
to read those parts which
makes the book funnier.
She helps me get a
really good ending.
I have trouble sometimes
coming up with titles,
so she helps me sometimes even
think up a really good title.
Even spelling the words
the words the right way,
it helps to have someone
to help you with that.
So, I just wanted to show you
what it looks like because
when I write a book, I
usually write it, maybe three
or four different times,
so I go through a lot
of sloppy copies
and rough drafts.
The illustrator for
Judy Moody is Peter,
his name is Peter
Reynolds and Peter also has
to go through rough drafts.
Imagine, like when you first
got the story, he had to figure
out what's Judy Moody
going to look like.
So, the first time I got
to see a sketch of her,
this is what she looks like,
but if she's supposed to be
in 3rd grade, what
do you think not,
might not be right
about this drawing?
Yeah, she's too short
and too young right.
She looks like she might
only be 4 or 5 years old.
So, I went to a classroom near
my house and took pictures
of 3rd graders and we
sent them to Peter,
and he made her taller, but
this time, this is supposed
to be the cover of
the very first book.
And, it's a funny book,
so you want the cover
to make you laugh, right.
So, he put this, a
different mood on the cover
that I thought would not
really make us laugh.
Doesn't she look too sad
to be on a funny book?
She looks like she just had
the most bummer summer ever.
So, now my editor went
back to Peter and said,
can we try maybe
a different mood
where she doesn't
look quite so sad.
So, now we're getting,
she's a little taller
and we're getting closer,
but now in the next one I got
to see, she looks kind of scary.
Doesn't she look scary like
she's making a me collage,
all about herself and her family
and her interests, but she looks
like she's going to hurt
somebody with those scissors.
>> I have an idea, you
should've, you should've,
you should've drew her
laying on the floor.
>> Megan McDonald: Yeah.
Exactly. That would've
been good.
So, finally Peter he had
to start all over again.
Finally, he drew Judy to look
like this and I love this sketch
because it looks like she's just
about to play a funny
joke on Stink, right?
And, she has her famous
tiger striped pajamas on
and she's the only kid with
the shirt with no words,
so she's going to write, I
ate a shark on her shirt.
This became the first
cover based on that sketch.
You guys read that one?
And, today, Judy has a brand-new
look and a brand-new cover
with her tiger stripes
and looks more
like this in full color, yeah.
Okay, now I want to skip
a little bit and I want
to tell you about my
brand-new book, "Judy Moody
and the Right Royal Tea Party".
This book, even though
Judy Moody is made
up in my imagination, I decided
I was going to write a book
where Judy was going to
do a family tree like,
not this complicated,
but she was going
to make her own family tree
and find out if she went back
to her great, great, great,
great, great, great, great,
great, 13 times great
grandparents, find out about
who she might be related to.
So, in order to do that, I had
to look up, I had to do a lot
of genealogy and family
history of the name Moody
because that's Judy's last name
and her family heritage, right?
So, when I looked up the
name Moody, I found out,
Judy would've been related to
some really interesting people,
like, there was a James
Moody who was on the Titanic.
And, he was like, a junior
officer, but he helped three,
for three different life
boats, he helped people
from the Titanic get
onto these life boats
and save their lives
before he himself died,
so she might've been related.
She thinks she's related to
James Moody from the Titanic.
When I first looked up the
name, sometimes if you look
up your last name, it wasn't
always spelled the same way.
So, when I looked up Moody,
if you go way back to the time
of Shakespeare and Queen
Elizabeth I in England,
her name would've been Modig,
M - O - D - I - G, Judy Modig
and Modig means brave
or bravery.
So, when I was looking that
up, I found the spelling also,
the spelling of Moody, it looks
like Mudeye, so Judy starts
to think she was also related to
a pirate, Mudeye Moody and then
when she goes back far enough
to the time of Shakespeare,
she starts to think
that she was related
to Queen Elizabeth herself.
And so, if she's related to the
queen, that means the queen,
the queen now, is, oh let me
skip ahead and I can show you,
the queen now of England
is about 90 years old.
She's been the queen
for a long time.
And, I'll skip ahead and
show you, wait let's see.
Let's see.
There we go, oh wait.
So, here's the queen today.
So, Judy decides, if
she has royal blood,
she would be related to
the Queen of England.
>> She looks like her a little.
>> Megan McDonald: She does.
And, the queen is 90
but she's very fancy.
She always wears these
colorful suits with a big hat.
Sometimes the hat has
all these flowers on it,
or she wears all of her jewels.
The question the queen
gets asked the most often
by kids is how heavy is
that crown because it has
so many jewels on it,
it's hard to walk with it
because it's so heavy.
So, Judy decides if
she has royal blood,
she just might be related
to the Queen of England,
she's pretty sure she is.
So, she thinks when I
give my report at school,
I'm going to have the most
exciting one because I'm going
to tell everybody I'm
related to the queen.
But when she gets up to give
her project, she finds somebody
who gives their project
in her class before her,
she finds out that, that person
did a bunch of research too
and that Judy may not be
related to the queen herself,
she may be related to
somebody else who worked
at the palace like, in the
time of Queen Elizabeth I.
There was an actual job
called the royal bug destroyer
and that person's job was
to squish or squash the bugs
that got into the palace, right.
So, Judy finds out
she might be related
to the royal rat catcher
instead of the queen,
so you have to read the book
to find out what happens.
But when I was doing the
research, I decided you know,
the Queen of England, they love
their tea in England, right,
so she loves to drink tea.
Every day at 4:00 they
have high tea in England
and high tea just
means you drink tea
and you have fancy little
cookies or something with it.
And so, Judy decides, hey,
I'm going to have a tea party
for my friends and its going to
be at 4:00 sharp and she's going
to hold it Toad Pee club tent.
So, she decorates the tent
all fancy and she sets
up the tea party and she
tells her friends to be there
at 4:00 sharp, but she writes it
in a secret code
and nobody comes.
At 4:00, nobody's
there and she thinks,
did they not crack the code,
but she's sure they
would've cracked the code.
So, then 4:01 comes, then
4:03, then 4:05, then 4:15
and they're not there
and she finally learns,
her friends thought a tea
parts sounded kind of boring,
so they weren't planning
on coming.
So, Judy has to think up
how can I make a tea party
really exciting?
And the reason it's a
right royal tea party,
in the back is a dictionary
of some funny words,
the way you say things
if you live in England.
So, if you look up, right
royal in the back, it says,
right royal means
extremely exciting and fun.
So, Judy decides she's going to
make up some fun games and one
of the games I made up, I
noticed when I was researching
about the queen, every picture
I saw, she always had a purse.
She always carried
her fancy purse.
Well, I read that
the Queen of England,
if you could believe
it, she's so fancy,
she owns over 300
different purses.
And, I started to think
what is in your purse
if you're the Queen
of England, right?
What would you carry in your
purse and she never leaves it
at home, at the Palace.
So, I had to do a
lot of research,
I probably should've
come to the Library
of Congress to look it up.
I had to do a lot of
research to find out,
what is in the queen's purse.
But I learned some really
interesting things that she has
in her purse, besides tea,
I should tell you the queen
also loves dogs and horses.
She usually has corgis,
right now she has four different
palace dogs, two are corgis
and two are adopted dogs.
So, she always has dogs, so I'm
going to pull some things out
and some of them would be in the
queen's purse and some wouldn't,
but I'm going to see if you can
guess if you think this would be
in the queen's purse, okay.
So, do you think the Queen of
England first of all would have
in her purse a tea bag?
>> Yes.
>> Megan McDonald: That's what
I thought, because they're crazy
for tea over there, right?
So, I thought she'd have a tea
bag, but hello, she's the queen,
she doesn't make her own tea.
The royal tea maker
makes the tea, right,
so she doesn't even have
to carry her own tea bag.
Do, you think she
would have a fancy pen?
>> Yes.
>> Megan McDonald: She does.
She always carries a
fancy pen in her purse.
Do you think she would have a
crossword puzzle in her purse?
>> No.
>> Megan McDonald: I
thought no way, but she does.
She always carries a crossword
in case she gets bored
or in case she needs to
use the fancy pen, right?
So, in that way the
queen and I are alike
because I always
have a crossword.
Do you think the queen
would have a candy necklace?
>> No.
>> Megan McDonald: No way.
Do you think Judy Moody
would have a candy?
>> Yes.
>> Megan McDonald: So,
Judy Moody has one.
The queen would probably
have real pearls
or diamonds or something.
We can't eat because I have
to show it to some other kids.
Do you think the queen would
have some mints in her purse?
>> Yes.
>> Megan McDonald:
She always has mints
because she's the queen, she
can't have bad breath, right?
Okay, do you think she
would have a fancy hanky?
>> Yes.
>> Megan McDonald: You
guys are good she does.
She always has a fancy hanky
in case she gets the sniffles.
And, the Queen of England
can't have boogers, right?
Okay, do you think she
would have a fancy lipstick?
>> Yes.
>> Megan McDonald: Yes.
In case she has to write
SOS like Nancy Drew?
>> No.
>> Megan McDonald: She
always has a fancy lipstick.
Do you think she would
have a dog treat?
I know. Isn't that crazy?
She always carries dog
treats in her purse.
That's how much the
queen loves dogs.
She doesn't leave the
palace without a dog treat.
Do you think she would
have a rubber ducky?
>> No.
>> Megan McDonald: She
doesn't actually carry this
in her purse, but I learned
when I was researching,
the queen actually has a rubber
ducky in the royal bathroom
and her rubber ducky wears
a crown, isn't that crazy?
Okay, now this one's really
crazy, do you think the Queen
of England would have in her
purse, a spark plug from a car?
>> No.
>> Megan McDonald: No, she
probably doesn't carry her own
but I learned, the queen even
though she's 90 years old,
she knows how to change
a spark plug in the car,
so if the royal palace car
breaks down, the queen can get
out and change the spark plug.
Pretty cool huh?
And, last of all, do you
think the queen would have
in her purse, a lucky charm?
>> Yes.
>> Megan McDonald:
You guys are good.
How'd you know that.
I thought no way would the
queen carry a lucky charm,
but she does.
She always has a lucky charm.
However, I couldn't find
out what her lucky charm is,
so if you ever get to meet the
Queen of England, please ask her
for me what is your lucky
charm so we can find out.
Okay, do you, does anybody
have a question you wanted
to ask today before
it's time to go?
Yeah?
>> Will you make anymore,
will you make anymore, books,
different books other
than Judy Moody?
>> Megan McDonald: Yes,
so the question is will I make
anymore different books other
than Judy Moody.
I've actually been working on
a new book for about 2 years
so far that's not
about Judy Moody.
And, this book is so different
because it's a fantasy,
so it's totally just made
up in my imagination,
but maybe someday
I'll finish it.
>> Will you ever like
have a clothing line
with like Judy Moody, like
across like a hoodie or a shirt?
>> Megan McDonald: Ooh,
I'm so glad you said
that since my publisher's
here today.
[ Laughter ]
>> We would love to do that
someday, but you can also go
to the Judy Moody website
and you can print out the
"I Ate a Shark" thing if you
want to make your own shirt,
so that's pretty cool too.
>> What I would like to
know is, how old are you?
>> Megan McDonald: How old am I?
Oh boy, okay, I am,
let's see, I usually try
to make it a math problem
so you can figure out.
Okay, so my first book came
out when I was 30 years old
and I've been writing books
for 30, almost 30 years.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Megan McDonald:
That's right, I'm 59, 58,
59 or 60, one of those.
I'm almost, I'm 59,
I'm almost 60.
Next year I'll be 60 years old.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Megan McDonald: Oh, thanks
you guys, keep saying that.
Did everybody get that?
Go ahead.
>> How long have you been
doing Judy Moody books?
>> Megan McDonald: Okay,
how long have I been
writing Judy Moody books?
Well, long enough that kids
who are in college now,
read Judy Moody when
they were young,
so the first Judy Moody
book came out in the 2000,
so for about 18 years.
So, actually a little
more because I had
to write the Judy
Moody book for a couple
of years before it came out,
so probably about 20 years
with Judy and Stink, so
they're like my family, right?
Oh, sorry, no go ahead, sorry.
>> Can we publish books
online, the Judy Moody books?
>> Megan McDonald:
Can you publish them?
>> Like buy them.
>> Megan McDonald: Oh yeah,
you can buy them online, yeah.
You can publish your own books.
>> Have you met any of
the actors in the movie?
>> Megan McDonald: Oh
yeah, so we were so lucky.
My husband and I
got to go on the set
for 3 months while
they filmed the movie.
Most writers don't usually
go be part of the movie,
so I was really, really lucky.
So, we met all the actors.
The girl who played Judy Moody
was 11 years old and she was
from Australia and she
had red hair that was kind
of messy like Judy Moody.
Well, she came from Australia,
and in Australia they
have a different accent
than we have here, so she had
to come a couple of months early
and she had to get
a dialect coach,
a person who could help
her to learn to speak
with an American accent.
And, then by the time we started
the movie, she was really good
at speaking like an
American would sound.
So, yeah, so we got to meet
all of the actors, all the,
all the kids who played parts.
Do you guys know who Urkel is?
I don't, you know Steve Urkel?
Steve Urkel, so he plays,
Judy has the most wonderful 3rd
grade teacher ever, Mr. Todd
and Urkel, his name
is Jaleel White,
plays Mr. Todd in the movie.
I know, see, pretty cool.
Yeah, so, you've got to go and
watch it again and look for him.
Yeah, exactly.
Anybody else?
>> Any questions?
>> Megan McDonald: Okay.
I think we're done.
Thank you all so much
for coming to the Library
of Congress today
to hear stories.
[ Applause ]